point
[Musique]
je trouve que c'est vraiment désolant ce
qui s'est passé que je trouve que le les
états unis dans les yeux du monde ont
perdu beaucoup de leur standing de c'est
vraiment une journée triste pour la
démocratie dans mon pays
[Musique]
mais c'est une accumulation depuis
quatre ans de chinois avec cette
résidence
[Musique]
avec les présidents les gens commencent
à regarder la vraie la vraie face la
vrai visage élevés du pays et avec ça ça
va vraiment montré comme sur les choses
dont je suis pas content que ça arrivait
parce que je suis de là bas et je pense
que la démocratie les plus importants
mais je
j'aimerais bien que ça change l'europe
comme les européens régal états unis
[Musique]